Aroma retail the sponsors of this
segment are here to keep your space
smelling good for the holidays I hung
out with our team to see what scents and
Deals they have in store
[Music]
take a moment to stop and smell the
aroma we are a scenting company
providing cents for of homeowners and
businesses alike you can find a Dollar
sense all along the Las Vegas Strip in
the major Resorts here and we we've been
making places smell nice for the last
six years now and during this time of
the year Aroma retail is all about happy
holiday smells and Deals it's becoming
to be the happy time at the Roma retail
this is where we offer special gift
packages and recommendations for for
gifts for family for friends for
business associates and vendors like we
have special uh discounts coming of
course for the biggest sale of the
seasons of Thanksgiving and Cyber Monday
Black Friday and all that before the
holidays one of our best choices for
presents is our hero product the scent
machine home Unit 101 one it's an easy
one to set up you set it up like a
thermostat program it it's going to send
up to 2000 square feet of surface an
easy plug-in into a regular outlet and
then you just fill out the fragrance oil
from the bottom get it into the canister
four ounces of fragrance oil will last
you about a month and if you want to
sense larger spaces and go high-tech we
have our app driven machine this is a
scent machine professional this can be
connected to HVAC and you can operate it
for your own little device through our
own Aroma retail app and they don't just
sell the products from here they make
them and they're Green certified old
factory so this is where the magic
happens it smells delicious in here yes
and we're pushing out about three to
five hundred packages a day oh look the
newly poor candles are in the process of
cooling down
foreign
[Music]
after seeing how they're made I gotta
smell them so we're back in the smelly
bar
why are we spelling that that smells so
good I smell a little
tree a little Citrus fruity
some spice a little cinnamon how am I
doing how am I doing very good okay what
is this one all right turn it around
oh happy holidays that makes sense
couldn't help that one now whether
you're looking for scents via machine
glassware or portable device Aroma
retail really has it all room Space
Fruit diffusers candle yes absolutely
oh that smells so good and an amazing
idea for uh for gifts this is our
portable version the travel scent
machine it can fit into your cup holder
that is such a great idea
[Music]
thank you to Aroma retail for sponsoring
that segment give them a call at
702-780-7370 or visit aromaretail.com
and that's where you can also find their
special offer 20 off site by Black
Friday through Cyber Monday with the
code
lvnow20 and if you want to go into the
shop and see it for yourself they're
doing 15 off at their smelly bar through
December 23rd JC